Kirra Rodan are there certain things
that people take too seriously you know
I think of everything that happens in
middle and high school 99% of it feels
like it's really important for the
future of your life and ten years later
you'll look back and say I cannot
believe I allowed that to bother me so
much it really didn't matter so I think
a lot of like high school melodrama is
something people take too seriously now
in adulthood I think that something
people often take too seriously is the
impression that others form of you right
and of course in work family of
relationships in society you can't
reasonably be completely disconnected
from the way you're perceived in the
world right if you say hey listen I'm
going to anywhere that I'm legally
allowed to be barefoot I'll be barefoot
there are going to be repercussions that
are that are real to that but what I
mean is I know a lot of people who are
overly focused even in their mid-20s
late 20s early 30s mid late thirties
early forties that really it met at
almost any age internally going over
what it is that someone else thinks
about them because of something that
they did and most of the time it really
doesn't make a difference and it's just
bad for you to be constantly worried
about what other people think or just on
the other side of the spectrum - there's
those people who say I don't care what
other people think yeah but I mean we're
social beings in the end and our
relationships matter to us maybe you
don't care so much about what some
random stranger thinks of you yeah but
when it comes to like your significant
other or your siblings or your parents
of course you care what they sure any
others that you have that people take
things people take too seriously what
about sports yes like this is those like
sport debate shows okay we'll get in
these passionate arguments about who's
going to win the Superbowl who's going
to win the next boxing match yeah I mean
first of all it's just a prediction I
mean you can you know bring some
statistics to the conversation or he
predicts based on you know past events
or what have you but does it does it
really matter in the end I don't know I
mean it wasn't really bananas hey man
that's fine I wasn't thinking so another
level the sports analysis shows but just
the idea of people taking sport like I
really like sports right and I've got my
teams
I follow I'm a Boston area sports fan I
follow the Argentinean men's national
team which now is in the middle of
playing World Cup qualifiers for the
2018 World Cup
I get it I like sports but when I see
adults that seem a little bit overly
affected by the results of their team
sometimes I wonder if they're fully
balanced in life I guess and I'm not
insulting anybody it genuinely comes
from a place of concern because in the
end once you the more I've learned about
economic issues and political issues in
history and and climate change and all
these different things I still enjoy
watching sports just as much but the
results don't mean nearly as much to me
in the grand scheme of things yeah you
shouldn't be missing work because your
sports team lost the day before and even
to bring this conversation full circle I
mean what about children's sports
leagues oh don't go crazy
your entire parents making sure that
their kids pitch a no-hitter or just you
know score the winning run and we'll
argue with other parents or the refs yes
I mean that is I and I've gone to a lot
of my little sister's soccer games and
there are some parents who seem a little
bit too invested where I wonder what's
going on with the parent that they feel
the need to be this this into in a sort
of hyperbolic way the specific minutiae
of what's going on in your ten-year-old
soccer game anyway those are some ideas
and karaoke sometimes people take
karaoke a little too seriously just
throw that one in there